all right fire yes fire origin girl
where are you from originally I'm
originally I'm from Egypt
um I grew up there until I was 14 and
then I moved to America I moved to New
York
with someone that uh paid for me
basically
um later on I became his wife
he's very abusive and stuff
the only good thing is that he let me go
to school
and I went to school and studied and
stuff but when I came back home it was a
nightmare he would uh do kind of like
torture uh things to me like make me sit
on the bed for hours and hours and make
me drink a lot of water and hold my
urine in and if I didn't I would get
whooped for it
um I never was allowed to speak to other
men or have friends or anything like
that if you only contacted to the
outside world was going to school I was
never allowed to cross the street by
myself even out to this day I have a
hard time crossing the street I gotta
remember green is stop red is go and
yellow was slow down right so you know
but I have a hard time Crossing yeah
Green is cool right but yeah I still
have that problem you know because of
all the trauma that I had you know
um so is this something that would
happen often in Egypt yeah yeah you're
not allowed to go anywhere without what
I'm saying being sold to yeah here yeah
to people yeah you can sell their
daughters too yeah yeah so their
daughters or pay Dowry to marry them
which is basically you're selling your
daughters you know so
yeah it's it's in a lot of abuse you
know you have no say in anything no no
nothing the only
I thought the only out that I had was
that he was he used to use drugs you
know
so then uh at 27 I started using drugs
as well you know just so that I felt
just so that he wouldn't beat me so he
wouldn't be cruel to me you know so I
started using as well you know and that
began with like alcohol then heroin and
then I used heroin for many years on and
off on and off then I started smoking
crack
you know I had my first child when I was
14.
and then my second child when I was
17 my third child when I was 22 my
fourth child when I was
28.
so you have four children I have four
children did you raise them yeah I
raised them but the state um would often
come in and take them from me because of
all the abuse and all the drug use and
stuff that was going on and my sisters
would would take them
um we had moved to Texas
and in Texas it was really bad like
really really bad like the neighbors
would hear him abusing me and stuff like
that so the cops came several times
finally they removed my children from my
care my two youngest children my two
oldest children were my sister back in
New York
and um
I continued using because I was in so
much pain you know that they took my
babies from me you know and
so I believe at 35 I moved back to to
New York
and an uncle of mine used to always pick
on me because I was a drug addict
telling me I was no good you know and
one day he threw acid on me
to acid on my chest my arms and these
are my ribs
my whole chest melted this is a
cadaverous skin I have two pig valves in
my heart and a muscle from my back in
front of my heart it was called thoracic
surgery I was they had to Fly Me To
Boston Massachusetts which was the only
hospital that did that kind of surgery
and I survived
and still I stayed with my husband
and then we moved here who was it that
through the acid do the acid attack and
everything my uncle yeah did he get that
nobody did anything about it the only
reason he got arrested was because there
was Witnesses and the witnesses said
something but as far as my husband or
anybody else nobody did anything about
it so your uncle did get convicted yeah
and uh he ended up dying in jail in
prison actually
and so then
things got really bad so we moved here
to California for a new start you know
first place we came was to Skid Row you
know and I remember walking here and as
soon as we hit Skid Row I heard like a
massive amount of noise and I looked at
my husband and I said where and how you
know
they literally were in hell
he started using methamphetamines got
more abusive got very bad started uh
doing
things he wasn't supposed to be doing
you know other women other men all kinds
of things like that you know and finally
I just I left you know
I ran away but then I left me by myself
out here you know so I told myself okay
you know I'm gonna try my best you know
to take care of myself you know take
showers because when I was with my
husband I hardly showered hardly to you
know because he was always on the go you
know we there was never no time to stop
you know
so I started taking care of myself stuff
like that I started going to the needle
exchange they started helping me out you
know
and uh then I continued to use heroin I
was up to like two grams a day I started
stealing boosting you know
I started uh smoking spice you know I
started popping pills I started doing
everything anything to ease the pain you
know to take it away or the reality of
where I was or what I was doing you know
I've gotten beat up I've gotten raped I
got my teeth kicked out one time because
somebody was trying to take my bag and I
wouldn't let it go so he kicked my teeth
in so I lost my front teeth
you know
um it's been difficult you know but
through it all I continue using I I just
don't
honestly I don't feel like there's an
out like I just feel like the only thing
that eases the pain and takes the noise
away is using you know and many times I
don't like the way I feel when I use
like if I smoke crack sometimes I hate
the way I feel what is your drug today
no my drug today was Fentanyl and
cracked yeah
and when I smoke crack then I'll drink
alcohol to calm down you know and that
requires money you know so then I boost
I steal for money you know and I'm even
afraid of doing that now you know
because there's so many police you know
because
so many users are you know hitting the
stores you know
but um I try to play the part you know I
try to dress nice and go to the store
and try to play the part you know but
many stores know me as well you know and
some stores you know they feel bad for
me and they just let me take the stuff
and let me go you know but I don't want
that you know I I want out but I don't
seem every time I take two two steps
forward I take 10 steps back because of
my drug addiction how old are you though
I'm 48. 48. and your kids do do you
still have contact with your kids I
speak to my I speak to my kids you know
they don't the last time I called my
daughter was the first time that I
called my daughter from moving
she thought I was dead because I hadn't
contacted her in about a year and a half
you know so I I contact her and stuff
you know and
I I lied to her I tell her that I'm not
using you know that I'm clean but it's
far from my reality you know I would
love to go back home but I can't go back
home
addict like this you know and now with
the fentanyl it's so difficult to detox
from fentanyl you know so I'm just I'm
really really struggling
um
my mental health is like declining
because I'm constantly paranoid I'm
constantly thinking people are after me
I'm constantly on my feet I carry a
weapon all the time you know
and I know I asked a lot to do with the
drugs you know but um I still continue
to do them because
this is my reality and
I need to do something to ease the pain
to take it away you know do you have any
family are you I have no family here
your parents are still around or not no
no I'm all alone here
after my husband left me after well
after I left him and we separated
I'm just by myself
are your parents alive my father is not
my mother you know but he doesn't speak
to me you know because
I was using drugs and I did the wrong
thing you know I'm not a good woman and
all that stuff you know I went through a
lot of views in my life so I have a lot
of trauma you're
you're no as a kid or as an adult no
I never knew I never knew love I never
knew what love was
you know
the only time I've had an inkling of how
it felt was when
my husband and I separated that pain
then I knew a little bit what love felt
like because it was gone but I was never
loved I was always abused and passed
around you know
like a like a dish rag you know
sold
and bought and treated bad and you know
just
whatever abuse whatever he wanted to do
to me I was just you know
I had to I had to take it you know
the only time I really felt love was
when I had my children
you know that's love you know
but do I feel up now no I don't feel
like anybody cares about me so I just
have to really take care of myself and
really like
just keep going you know what's your
biggest fear now my biggest fear is
being murdered
being murdered my biggest fear
it's dangerous down here it's very
dangerous especially when you're a woman
and you're attractive you know
if you don't pay attention to anybody
you know they
they know they just
they don't like you for whatever reason
you know
and it's it's difficult it's very
dangerous I always have to walk on my
toes walk with a weapon and always be
watching every four sides you know but
what weapon do you carry I carry a knife
I used to have a gun but my friend took
it from me
yeah
I'm very good with knives
you still have hope for your future
getting of course off the streets and of
course I always have hope you're giving
housing to people sometimes now yeah
yeah I've been trying to do that you
know
I've been trying really hard to do
whatever I can
but yeah I hope yeah I've been I've had
hope since I was a little girl
you know when you dream those are hopes
hopes and dreams
you point a finger at what exactly
LED you down this path would you say it
was the
the culture you came from that
the abuse the abuse and the fact that
you were sold at 14. yeah that I was
sold at 14 and following my husband
everywhere he went you know that was the
biggest Factor the the trauma
you know the pain
that's what led me down this path
do you have any good memories of your
childhood or your life
just being at my grandpa's house
by the blind Vineyard
that that was good times
he used to protect me a lot but then he
passed away
you know it's been your roughest period
this has been my roughest part in my
life yeah
the roughest time of my life is right
now
I really I really struggle every day and
I really
sometimes I just want to lay down I
don't want to get up I don't want to do
anything but I know if I don't get up
I'm going to be sick you know I'm going
to be dope sick and I'm not going to
have anything and you know so I have to
push myself to get up you know and
there's a saying out there that they say
about me they say that my legs have no
stop signs because I'm always walking
really fast you know but I have to I
learned to walk fast you know almost
like an athlete that's why I'm so much
in shape because I walk so fast you know
because I want in and out you know get
my things get out and I I don't want
anybody to follow me or know where I'm
going or know where I sleep at night you
know because I sleep alone outside
you know so I don't want people to know
where I sleep or I rest my head because
I don't want anybody to come and hurt me
while there has been people that have
hurt me and that's why I I don't I don't
sleep around this area anymore I go
somewhere else and I I hide and you know
have you tried to quit
I have
I have I really have
but that I know it's not easy it's not
easy and for me I just feel an emptiness
you know I feel like there's something
missing
sometimes reality is too much for me
it becomes too real and too painful
you know
I was talking to this guy one day I was
done a career time nice guy
he told me you know maybe you need
counseling maybe you need to see a
psychiatrist you know
because I was thinking there was people
following me and he was like no no
there's nobody following you you just
have trauma you know
and I believe him it's true I know that
I have a massive amount of trauma and
bad memories you know I have many
sleepless nights you know
you have to sleep with one eye open
you know then the nightmares come then
you can't sleep at all
yeah
it's difficult in fact what would you
say is the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
it was a poor lesson I've learned in my
life is to keep your mouth shut
don't say anything
be humble and be understanding
she No Evil Hear no evil speak no evil
all right fire thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I wish you
the best of luck out here yes thank you
sir